c'est une situation qu'on ne connaissait
pas que portent à notre connaissance un
collectif donc des communications de
copies d'écran qui montre un des
échanges bien sûr nature sexuelle entre
un majeur et une très jeune miller donc
moi je les ai pris effectivement comme
il était c'est-à-dire un commencement de
preuve et l'anc est qu'on a réalisé
l'interpellation de l'auteur nous a
permis de confirmer effectivement les
soupçons ça fait quand même nouveau en
france c'est le premier cas en haute
saône
comment la justice française doit se
comporter par rapport au travail de ces
collective alors effectivement c'est
nouveau c'est très original
je crois que la justice ou d'adapter à
notre époque qui sera de plus en plus
des révolutions des révélations de faits
par les réseaux sociaux donc moi j'ai
pris tel quel
la chambre criminelle de la colonisation
nous autorise à recueillir des éléments
parfois obtenu dans des conditions un
peu irrégulière comme commencement de
preuve c'est ce que nous allons faire
et effectivement je crois que l'on vient
de la confirmer ça nous a permis
d'identifier effectivement une personnes
attirées par les mineurs là vous
travaillez sur le matériel saisi et en
essayant de voir s'il ya d'autres cas et
comme vous dites comment se pendre de
preux et maintenant c'est vous qui
prenez le relais du travail dans lequel
voilà donc la brigade de recherche a
pour mission effectivement d'identifier
d'éventuelles autres victimes à travers
tout ce qu'on capte sur l'ordinateur
et puis également une expertise
psychiatrique qui a diligenté
effectivement par rapport à cette
attitude est à l'attirance de cet homme
pour les plus jeunes il ya un danger que
en france fasse de villèle comme dans sa
prière anglo saxons où on jette en
pâture des noms de personnes où il y
avait des règlements de compte qui
peuvent se se faire de manière sauvage
oui j'appelle tout le monde à la
vigilance le bon comportement s'est
signalé ce type de fait à la plateforme
pharos du ministère de l'intérieur avec
des enquêteurs spécialisés le risque
effectivement et je mets en garde
effectivement tout ce qui le ferait ça
serait de communiquer l'identité
effectivement de ces personnes qui je le
rappelle sont présumés innocents tant
qu'ils n'ont pas été définitivement
jugés
et puis le risque aux également c'est
qu'ils aient des vengeances il est vrai
que quand on regarde ce qui se passe
dans les pays anglo saxons il ya parfois
des violences qui sont commises sur ces
personnes à l'heure même encore une fois
qu'ils n'ont pas été définitivement
condamné